"GUTFELD!" UP NEXT.
[APPLAUSE]
MUSICA PHYSICAL >> Greg: HAPPY
WEDNESDAY EVERYONE, AND IT IS
WEDNESDAY, ANOTHER GLORIOUS A
DAY IN THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
CHINA AND WHERE EVERY DAY THE
GREAT UNIFIER LEADS US DOWN A
PATH OF CHAOS.
BUT BEFORE WE DIVE IN, IT'S TIME
FOR SEVEN JOKES.
NOT TO BE CONFUSED WITH THE CNN
LINEUP.
>> Announcer: GREGG'S SEVEN
JOKES ♪ ♪
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE THAT
MUSIC.
AND WE AFFORD A TEACHER HAS BEEN
ARRESTED FOR HAVING SACKS WITH A
STUDENT IN HER CAR ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT IT SHE SAID SHE
WAS SHOWING THE KID HOW TO DRIVE
A STICK.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE'S BEEN FIRED, ALTHOUGH THERE
IS A SCHOOLWIDE PETITION
DEMANDING SHE STILL TEACH
DRIVER'S ED.
[LAUGHTER]
TWO, KATIE COURIC IS GETTING
CALLED A MISOGYNIST FOR A NEW
MEMOIR OR SHE TRASHES OTHER
WOMEN AND HER CONNECTION TO
PURVIS LIKE MATT LAUER AND
JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
DEFENDANTS SAY THAT'S UNFAIR AND
POINT OUT TO HER CHARITY WORK
FOR THE TED BUNDY FOUNDATION.
WHEN TOLD BE, BECAUSE SHE'S
BEING CALLED MISOGYNIST BY OTHER
WOMEN, SHE REPLIED, TELL BITCHES
THOSE TO SHUT UP AND MAKE ME A
SANDWICH.
ACTRESS/COMEDIAN/HAS-BEEN SARAH
SILVERMAN SLAMS HOLLYWOOD
FORECASTING NON-JEWISH ACTORS TO
PLAY JEWISH CHARACTERS AS AN
EXAMPLE OF JEW FACE, WHICH IS
WHAT YOU WOULD EXPECT FROM A
PERFORMER WHOSE DONENESS.
VICE PRESIDENT, IRS HAS FINALLY
SOLD HER D.C. CONDO FOR
1.85 MILLION.
THE BAD NEWS, ACCORDING TO A NEW
DEMOCRATIC BILL, THE NEW BUYER
OWES HER NOTHING BECAUSE LICATA
WILL PAY FOR ITSELF.
[LAUGHTER]
MEGHAN TRAYNOR AND HER HUSBAND
ADMITTED TO HAVING TWO TOILETS
NEXT TO EACH OTHER SO THEY COULD
GO TO THE BATHROOM AT THE SAME
TIME.
WHEREAS THE EXTRA TOILET AND
BRIAN STELTER'S BATHROOM IS A
SPARE.
AND THAT'S SEVEN JOKES.
[APPLAUSE]
I GIVE IT 4 OUT OF 7, MAYBE
THREE.
RIGHT.
SO WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL THOSE
PROGRESSIVE WOMEN WHO ONCE CARED
ABOUT WOMEN, ESPECIALLY WOMEN IN
POWER?
WELL IT ALL GOES AWAY IF THAT
YOU AREN'T THERE KIND OF WOMAN.
SUDDENLY OPPRESSION IS
NECESSARY.
IS OUR FAVORITE SACK OF SPOILED
POTATOES.
JOY BEHAR EXPLAINED THAT
ACTIVISTS HAD TO GO INTO THE
BATHROOM TO CONFRONT
SENATOR SINEMA.
>> IT'S M.I.A. ALL OVER THE
PLACE, SHE'S NOT AROUND.
THEY CALL HER TO HAVE A MEETING,
THEY TRIED TO GET HER ON THE
PHONE.
SHE DOESN'T -- SHE WAS LIKE A
MISSING PERSONS OF THIS IS THE
ONLY ALTERNATE IF THEY HAVE.
>> Greg: EASY FOR HER TO SAY,
NO ONE IS BRAVE ENOUGH TO FOLLOW
JOY BEHAR INTO THE CAN.
TALK ABOUT A DEATH WISH.
6 FEET OF DISTANCE VERSUS THAT
BLAST RADIUS?
THE ONLY TIME I AGREE WITH
DR. FAUCI ABOUT WEARING MULTIPLE
MASKS.
SO KYRSTEN SINEMA BEING M.I.A.
MAKES IT OKAY FOR HER TO BE
BULLIED IN THE BATHROOM?
BY JOY'S LOGIC, RIGHT WING LOGIC
SHOULD BE ALIGNED 15 DEEP IN
FRONT OF A STALL WHEN, CHRIS IS
DROPPING THE KIDS OFF AT THE
POOL.
TALK ABOUT SOMEONE BEING M.I.A.,
SHE'S THE FIRST VP IN HISTORY
WHO CAN ONLY BE FOUND WITH AN
AMBER ALERT.
BUT MY FAVORITE HYPOCRITE, THE
SHAPES SHIFTER KIERSTEN POWERS
HIM USED TO SPEND MANY A LONELY
NIGHT LECTURING ASKED HOW MEAN
WE ARE TO WOMEN IN POLITICS AND
THAT LACK OF GRACE WAS
DESTROYING THE VERY FABRIC OF
AMERICA.
BUT NOW THAT SHE'S ON CNN HER
OPINION SUDDENLY CHANGES.
IT'S AMAZING WHAT 300 BUCKS PER
WEEK AND FREE HAIR AND MAKEUP
WILL DO.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE CASE.
SHE CLAIMS SHE WAS
FLABBERGASTED, FLABBERGASTED
THAT PEOPLE WERE UPSET OVER
BULLIES CHASING HER INTO THE
STALL INTO REASONING WAS IF SHE
DIDN'T WANT PEOPLE TO FOLLOW HER
INTO THE BATHROOM, SHE SHOULDN'T
HAVE GONE INTO THE BATHROOM.
ALL THAT'S MISSING AS SHE WAS
ASKING FOR IT.
YES, HOW DARE THE SENATOR USE A
BATHROOM AND HOW DARE SHE SOLD
HER WELL-ROUNDED MODERATE
ANSWERS FOR THE WORLD TO SEE.
AND WHY THOUGH IT NEEDED TO USE
THE TOILET?
JUST DO WHAT OTHER DEMOCRATS
THAT INTER IS PASS ON HER
CONSTITUENTS.
SO IT'S THE TALE OF TWO
KIERSTEN'S.
WHEN DENIED A SAFE SPACE IN A
RESTROOM AND THE OTHER ON THE
IDEA OF COMMON DECENCY.
SORRY POWERS, THERE IS A TIME AT
A PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE
DEMANDS AND IT'S NOT IN THE
LADIES ROOM.
TRUST ME, I'VE TRIED.
HERE POWER SHAMING A WOMAN
FREEZE IN THE BATHROOM WHILE
EXCUSING THE BULLYING TACTICS OF
THE LEFT.
THIS FROM A WOMAN WHO ONCE SAID
"IN OUR PUGILISTIC TAKE NO
PRISONERS ERA PREACHING GRACE
TOWARD THOSE ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE POLITICAL FENCE IS DECIDEDLY
COUNTERCULTURE.
THAT'S ONE OF BOWERS QUOTES
ABOUT GRACE.
IT TURNS OUT SHE'S ABOUT AS
GRACEFUL AS BIDEN HONEST THEIR
CLIMBER.
ONE THING IS FOR CERTAIN
COMPASSES GOT GOT THEM UP BEHIND
HER AND THE BULLYING OF A SINEMA
WAS CHEERED ON TWITTER BUT YOU
THINK THOSE WHO PREACH GRACE
WOULD HANDLE THE MOB.
BUT ONCE POLITICS POISONS MINDS
THAT YOU HAVE IDIOTS JUSTIFYING
ALL SORTS OF EXTREMISM.
IT'S A SPECTRUM FROM CONFRONTING
PEOPLE AT DINNER TO PHYSICALLY
ATTACKING THEM.
WE CALLED IT ANTIFA, BUT THEY
CALLED AN IDEA.
MEANWHILE ANGRY MOMS AND DADS
ARE BEING TREATED LIKE THEY ARE
PLACING IEDs AND THE FACULTY
PARKING LOT.
IT'S AN EXTENSION OF THE ROOM.
SPITTING ON US AND THREATENING
TO KILL US, NO CHARGES.
FAKE ANTHRAX AND DEATH THREATS
SENT TO OUR HOME, NO CHARGES.
NOW WE JUST LEARNED THE PERSON
WHO CALLED THE RAND SENATE
OFFICE TO SHOOT US WILL NOT BE
CHARGED.
I WONDER IF KIERSTEN POWERS
THOUGHT SHE HAD IT COMING?
IF YOU WANT TO BE THREATENED
WITH DEATH, MAYBE STAY OUT OF
THE LIMELIGHT.
RETURN TO THE KITCHEN AND KEEP
YOUR MOUTH SHUT.
IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH OF THE
FEMALE LEFT HAVE IN COMMON WITH
THOSE LADY HATERS AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT THEIR SANDALS OR
BEARDS.
THEY BOTH SHARE THE DELIGHT AND
COERCION AS A MEANS TO SILENCE
UPPITY WOMEN.
THE TALIBAN WILL STONE A WOMAN
FOR SHOWING AN INCH OF ANKLE AND
THE LEFT WILL BE RATE OF
POLITICALLY MODERATE WOMAN FOR
SHOWING AN OUNCE OF GUMPTION.
BIDEN MAY BE SENDING THEM
WEAPONS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HER PARENTS CAME THIS
CLOSE TO NAMING HER BMW.
MERCEDES SCHLAPP.
AND HE GREW UP ON A RAISIN FARM
AND TONIGHT HE IS RAISING OUR
IQs.
A SENIOR FELLOW OF THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION AND AUTHOR OF THE
GREAT NEW BOOK "THE DYING
CITIZEN" VICTOR DAVIS HANSON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
HE'S LIKE A DISCOUNT MARTINI,
DRY AND FULL OF CHEAP GIN.
WESTERN RAZOR.COM OWNER DAVID
ANGELO.
AND WHEN SHE GIVES BLOOD, IT
SERVED ON THE ROCKS WITH THE
SALTED RIM.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
BEFORE I GET TO YOU VICTOR, I
HAVE TO GET SOMETHING OUT OF THE
WAY.
DAVE WHEN YOU WERE LAUGHING ON
THE SHOW HE WAS A SPOKESMAN FOR
THIS RAZOR COMPANY AT A NOW YOU
KIND OF LIKE WORKED HER WAY UP
THE LADDER AND IT NOW YOU OWNER,
AND LIKE A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THE COMPANY, THIS IS
YOU WITH A PO BOX.
>> WILL HE DO HAVE A PO BOX, WE
GET SO MUCH FAN MAIL FROM
SATISFIED CUSTOMERS WHO VISIT
WESTERN RAZOR.COM THAT WE JUST
HAD TO EXPAND CAPACITY.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT.
SPEED WHEN YOU ARE THE OWNER AND
SPOKESMAN, IT'S JUST YOU AND ONE
RAZOR.
YOU ONLY HAVE ONE RAZOR.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
RAZORS AND THEY ARE ALL
AVAILABLE NOW AT WESTERN
RAZOR.COM.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> THIS IS THE CALIBER OF GUESTS
THAT I GET, EVEN AT LEADING LATE
NIGHTS.
THANK GOD VICTOR YOU ARE HERE TO
SAVE US FROM YOUR EVIL MAN.
WE ARE SEEING THIS WEIRD TREND
WHERE WE ARE DECRIMINALIZING
CRYING AND CRIMINALIZING BASIC
CITIZENS AND BASIC DECENCY.
IF YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS IN WRITING ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS, WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> THERE IS ONE CONSISTENCY AND
ITS POWER AND IDEOLOGY.
50 YEARS AGO I WAS A STUDENT AND
WE ALL HEARD ANY MEANS NECESSARY
AND IT WAS MALCOLM X AND THAT IT
WAS SO WHETHER THEY SWARM AROUND
PAUL OR SHIMMER IS IN COURT WITH
THE MOB AND THEY SAY WE ARE
COMING AFTER YOU, THAT'S OKAY.
AND IT WAS OKAY TO GO AFTER
SINEMA BUT IT'S NOT OKAY IF
YOU'RE CONSERVATIVE.
THERE IS CONSISTENCY BECAUSE
PEOPLE WITH SUPERIOR MORALITY
FEEL THAT THE MEANS ARE
JUSTIFIED BECAUSE THEY ARE ENDS
ARE SO MUCH MORE NOBLE.
THEY ARE INTELLECTUAL AND
ENLIGHTENED AND THE REST OF US,
WE JUST DO WHAT THEY TELL US.
IT'S A CONSISTENCY AND POWER OF
THE LEFT AND THEY DON'T BELIEVE
IN THE PRINCIPLE OF CONSISTENCY
AND THEY'VE BEEN PRETTY
EFFECTIVE ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: AND THAT'S TRUE
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO BE GROWING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
KRAUTHAMMER BUT IT WAS, THEY
THINK WERE WRONG AND WE THINK
THEY ARE EVIL.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU CAN FOLLOW
ME.
I MIGHT HAVE TO GIVE YOU WOULD
LIKE WE'VE GOT A BOOT.
A CAMERAMAN IF YOU CAN GRAB
THAT.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
FEMINIST WOMEN WHO ARE ALL GIRL
POWER.
SHE'S NOT EVEN A REPUBLICAN.
>> SHE MIGHT SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
I'M DONE WITH THESE DEMOCRATS.
IT'S APPALLING THAT NOT ONLY
WOMEN WON'T SUPPORT SINEMA IN
THIS CASE AND THEY ALLOW FOR
THIS BULLYING BEHAVIOR.
MIND YOU THEY CRITICIZE
DONALD TRUMP FOR BULLYING
BEHAVIOR BUT THEY THEMSELVES ARE
ADOPTING THIS BULLYING BEHAVIOR.
AND WASN'T JOE BIDEN SUPPOSED TO
COME IN AND BRING DECENCY AND
MORALITY BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE?
AND HE'S ALLOWING FOR THIS TO
OCCUR AND NOT DEFENDING SINEMA,
IT'S BEEN AN OUTRAGE.
>> Greg: IS BUILDING BULLIES
BETTER.
DAVID, THAT CAME TO ME AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
WHERE WOULD I HAVE THE JOB
INTERVIEW?
>> WE CAN ARRANGE.
YOU ARE HIRED.
I'LL SEND YOU -- WHAT IS IT, A
1099?
WHO CARES AT THIS POINT, I IT'S
OFF THE BOOKS.
UNDER THE TABLE.
>> Greg: I WOULD GET PAID FOR
EVERY RAZOR YOU SELL.
ALL RIGHT.
DO YOU HAVE A THOUGHT ON THIS
TOPIC?
I'M SURE YOU DO, YOU'RE A SMART
GUY.
>> YES.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW I THOUGHT OF THE VIDEO,
I'M SITTING IN THE BATHROOM AND
THIS BIG CONFRONTATION BUT IT
WAS ACTUALLY GOOD THAT IT
HAPPENED BECAUSE SINEMA IS
ANCHORED THE DEMOCRATS AND THAT
WAS A BATHROOM THAT HILLARY
CHOSE TO ASSASSINATE HER IN.
AND THANKFULLY THEY BROUGHT THE
CAMERA AND SHE DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
ELLERY WAS IN THE NEXT STALL
WITH THE PIANO WIRE.
AND IT SAVED HER LIFE.
>> Greg: IT YOU KNOW, NO ONE
HAS TALKED ABOUT THAT, THAT
ACTIVIST SAVED KYRSTEN SINEMA'S
LIFE.
>> WE ALWAYS HAVE TO LOOK FOR
THE OTHER ANGLES.
>> Greg: YES, LIKE THE ANKLES
ON THE FACE.
YOU NEED A REALLY GOOD SAVER.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU ARE THE NUMBER
ONE COPYWRITER.
>> Greg: I HAVE A HARD TIME
WITH MY ADAM'S APPLE, I CAN'T
GET RID OF IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I'M CONSIDERING A TOTAL GENDER
CHANGE.
YOU'RE A WOMAN, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
YES.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU SEE PEOPLE
LIKE A KYRSTEN SINEMA OR JOY
SAYING IT'S OKAY TO TREAT PEOPLE
THIS WAY, --
SPEAK OF THE JEZEBEL ARTICLE WAS
SO INTERESTING BECAUSE IT'S OKAY
TO BULLY KYRSTEN SINEMA IN THE
BATHROOM.
I RESEARCHED THIS.
OKAY.
I DID SOME RESEARCH AND I TYPED
IN STREET HARASSMENT AND
CATCALLING INTO Jezebel.com
AND THERE WERE LIKE 170 ARTICLES
ABOUT HOW BAD IT IS FOR PEOPLE
TO COMMENT ON YOUR BODY WHILE
YOU ARE WALKING.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
ALSO THINK IT WAS BAD FOR PEOPLE
TO COMMENT ON YOUR CHARACTER
WHILE YOU ARE POOPING.
IF YOU THINK THOSE WOULD GO
TOGETHER BUT YOU ARE WRONG.
I'M NOT SOMEONE WHO WORRIES TOO
MUCH ABOUT SOCIAL NORMS, I THINK
THEY HOLD US BACK.
BUT THE ONE WHERE PEOPLE DON'T
FOLLOW YOU INTO THE BATHROOM AND
FILM YOU, I LIKE THAT ONE.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD ONE, I
DON'T WANT TO DECRIMINALIZE
THAT.
>> YOU DON'T WORRY IF SHE TAKES
TOO LONG TO RESPOND TO AN EMAIL,
THAT'S WHAT SHE ASKED F